I think, looking back, I have to say
that the timing of the
IPO was of course great. I did
n't really notice that in the situation. To be honest,
I have to say that
at the time I was more in favor of postponing the IPO for another
two years
Of course, it was a fatal
mistake in
retrospect, but no one saw it coming,
um, and it wasn't clear to me at the time
that we were basically at the peak of the
rating, so I assumed
the costs would continue
to rise and everyone else is also
welcome to the  OMR Podcast he
's back after a slightly longer break than in
previous years,
but he's back again and
I think I'm fresh from boxing training and you
can
now have your podcast here, but
I took a shower afterwards, yes I
actually did. I don't often make it to the
gym  But once a week
I try and uh boxing and fighting is now
a text scene without the big thing
so you're a bit on the trail
of them
magic yes so I yes it's really just
a half felt ne of such tech
entleurs then  Somehow
I do boxing and MMA, I've actually been doing it
for five years or something like that,
but it's more like a workout because I find
the gym kind of boring a lot of the time
and then I had a personal
trainer and he noticed that I was
constantly getting rejections and was actually always
really up for it  and then it was
suggested that you do boxing and that I've never gotten
tired of it,
I've never gotten into a fight, and I'm not particularly aggressive
I'm a little bit motivated to
at least not have to cancel sports all the time
and then we somehow do
half an hour of boxing and then
half an hour of strength training but now
for boxing he doesn't really hit
back seriously,
but there are no plans to break down
with Robert any time soon
somewhere or something that would be so funny I
celebrate it from this mask male
said argument and fight so
if I always had a little more time with you
or something like that I would feel like
fighting in a
contest but the probability that
I'm going to lose somehow various times
first of all or who would get a black eye go
up so that's why
it's more relaxed so that the two of them are there
on such a worldwide stage so to speak
these violent topics there so you can
see anyway
so I thought I think that would be the
craziest thing  Media spectacle of all time
so it would probably be the most
watched boxing fight of all time and I
'm sure or hey they weren't
boxing but MMA or doing Gigi,
well I mean you've
never boxed before. Boxing has nothing
to do with violence  yes, the one I think I'm
also in my
boxing camps from time to time, not camps or
boxing studios or something like that, or come on
people come in who just
don't want to meet people on the street, but I thought the
boxing stall was the most peaceful one there  At
times it's just a sport that's
a lot about technique and that has
nothing to do with violence. I had exactly
the same look, so when my
trainer suggested boxing to me, she
said she wasn't keen on it, I'm
the most peaceful person I've ever
been  I've never had a fight
before. I really don't feel the need to
fight myself and then I
understood that boxing and martial arts do
n't have anything to do with violence,
but rather with technique, with
disciplines, with responsiveness, with
concentration, but you see the
two now  so back to
Elan and Mark to turn it
so it's unusual that you
two tect guys came away with such storylines at the same time
yes but I
don't know why it works
but prophet because I mean elemental mask
he started it and felt it
but  Streets actually pushes more or so of
course
I don't need one yet so
my real prismotive I ca
n't even imagine what strikes me as so
impulsive and so unstrategic
in certain topics in his business
team he is certainly very strategic
but otherwise in his communication  He's
so impulsive, that's what makes him so
successful for me. I ca
n't even imagine that he sat there and
thought about it. I want to do
something like this now, or do
you think it was an impulse and did he notice,
okay, something is coming  Afterwards, it's
fun, you get even more attention, keep
going, so I think a lot of
his communication behavior, so to speak,
is more simply
driven by impulse and then what works
because you don't know anymore and what doesn't work like that
and that somehow worked world class,
exactly
seen  to still
come out again after his boring image, well then somehow
location I think I posted exactly on
Instagram
and then he also said to himself that he
would finish the element so badly,
so I even think
I would finish any mask with
my minimal technique because  just
trained and you can't
win in a fight against someone
who doesn't have much more
technique so it's my learning
without ever being in a fight but
basically even in my with my basic
amateur knowledge I know that someone with
Technique, even if the
other person is stronger, they would always take off
because you can fight against someone
who can box
and you won't even hit him,
so
he has no chance. In my
opinion,
yes, I train every day
If
the world's business leaders are now included, so to
speak, the two of them are quite good at showing themselves naked in the evening and
then
discussing things like that, or they
used to be and you can see
that now, I don't know, I don't know,
I have the feeling that you  the absolute
reversal away from the patriarchy and
somehow had masculine macho is
yes that is masculine macho had and
starrights actually two CEOs who
are in competition with each other who
like somehow I don't know on Game of
Thrones now want to fight it out like
that  Instead of them having a
target level fight on pieces of paper, so to speak, that's
so old school actually, um, but I
don't know, but it
works somehow, people, we're
already talking about it now, yes it
works, so I do
n't really understand why it is  So
I
was almost a little bit about it, or
I'm fascinated by it, I need
to see something, of course, something like that from an
attention point of view and stuff like that,
but it also has to be almost a
little bit disturbing, no, there will be guys who have
come back with things like that,
even if you say that's not the case now
Violence and that's kind of the way it is
now in WoW but
it's funny if it
looks funny and if the two of them then continue to
laugh about it with the Colosseum and
something like that
next to boxing, you were at least
together with a lot of mine now
I heard from colleagues at the
festival, yes, exactly, I am, so today is
Monday. I was at our festival yesterday until yesterday, that is,
until Sunday evening
when he attacked on Thursday evening. I
just saw my half app iPhone health
app that I burned 80 km
in three days  So I've been
on the road a lot,
so I really enjoy it, so I
don't always enjoy everything at work,
it's also a lot, somehow, almost just in the
last 12 months, I would
say 95% seriousness and
I'll say things that you could have
done without, but that
I'm having a lot of fun with it, but it's
also work, so there's not a
lot of work at the moment, but of course I still have to
fight for a bit of response,
there are a lot of business partners
of ours and this is, above all,
a marketing event for us  So
I believe very strongly in building
brands by creating
experience of the emotionality of
media products at the end of the day. I
think it's a good
example of how well it works, so
the brand awareness from above is
very high now
Even though you've never run a TV commercial,
even though you've never done
anything, I haven't used the classic channels,
why because people
are more inclined
to remember media brands and are even more
inclined
to remember entertainment brands, like Joko, for
example  Yes, almost everyone knows him,
even though he has never run a commercial,
why because people
need fewer sticking points if they
connect the point of contact with emotionality
and from that idea
we only ultimately try to do things like the about you
Pangea Festival  to
actually establish our brand
and boost it through
actually I'm so Trojan
horse-like advertising
and the festival 20,000 participants
is now really a big
festival is growing very very successfully
so I think the biggest artists were
Batman's Jay k.i.z from because of Lisbeth a
lot of electro DJs and  so on but
that is exactly the success of the
festival this is the festival with
probably the lowest percentage
music budget um now a small
part goes into music the largest part goes into
building worlds of
sports activities of workshops of
cultural programs there are hundreds of
workshops that do this  You can do anything from
some great yoga to I don't know
batik a little bit to building your
own which I skimboard skateboard
if there's dirt bike riding wakeboarding
fitness at the lake in the north and it's
basically an adventure weekend and we
started there five years ago
because I  The feeling I had now was
completely from my work, based on my
amateur gut feeling, my
feeling was that you have the times of festivals
where it's just about headliners and you just
go there, somehow, I don't know, get drunk on
the campsite until 4 p.m.
and then somehow get yourself  stands in front of the
main stage and does halli galli for four hours
then goes back to the
tent that didn't seem up to date at all to me
the feeling that people want
activity, they want a whole day program
and they don't just want to drink and
somehow main stage but they
actually want a kind of
adventure weekend  with
everything with sport and activity with art with
culture with music with party and that
's basically the pangeas of the slogan so
awaken the inner child in you or be
or rediscover being a child, so to speak
for a weekend and that
actually works very well so
festival  -industry is also a mega
crisis, most festivals have
visitors
but I think they also have visitors, of course they
are always sold out but also
the demand is
actually very good at all festivals or has declined
very sharply at almost all festivals
except for the festivals
More like this experience,
this weekend experience, in principle,
play to Disneyland for
adults, in principle for a weekend
and that always works
very well on the Pangea. There are also other
examples where it works very well
because I think that's
what I mean, I think that  Most
people don't look at that alone,
but rather the book Tomorrowland because of
the experience and I think that
this type of festival
is more forward-looking than the
festivals here that are purely about what's
going on on their own, so I was
gigantic in business a few weeks ago  So what
these two Belgian brothers have built there
and in fact there are of course
all the top DJs there, not all of them,
but a lot of them, but at the same time
I don't have the feeling that that
's the reason for the people
coming  You also invest in
all the landscapes and all the decorations and
the food that's there and how it's
done, it's
really cool and now
ships ship the world and then
you're close to  Brussels and
then when one is built then
somehow a few weeks later then
somehow in Brazil and so on and
then somewhere in Asia so it's
really a monster business that
also went bankrupt in a
pandemic but used it and then a
share  to buy back
and the guy, one of the
brothers, is already really stepping on the gas, so it's
very impressive, but in the
end the brand is a real one. It has to create something
to build a global brand out of Europe. There have
n't been that many in the last few
years  So now they are in the
fashion sector on maybe yes
otherwise there is little going on in the
automotive sector I would invest
next day in the Spotify sector but very
little and Tomorrowland is its niche
but is a global brand in which
people from all over the world go to Brussels
so people with  Mexican flag and
somehow from Asia it's really like
an Olympics just for musicians yes that's that's
exactly that's Tomorrowland caught
me too I've
never been there now I still generally want to
have been to festivals here so to speak
except now so in the past
We haven't been sitting in the last ten years
but I would have been
caught by what it embodies
because I think people associate
Tomorrowland with experience, something
new, something blatant, something unseen, an
experience and the name says it in a
way  a kind of
utopia of the world and Pangea the name
Pangea comes from the fact that Pangea was,
so to speak, the original continent and all the
continents were together and we
want to create the world as it
should actually be and that
as a basic idea I think is something
extreme  Nowadays it
's a totally zeitgeist because
I think a lot of people
aren't actually 100% satisfied
with their lives and do
n't think a lot of things are that cool that are
going on somehow left and right and
then actually see themselves out of
their lives for a weekend  Being able to escape from everyday life
and it's possible for
everyone, so I'm a happy person
but I'm also happy about a
weekend from old age, no escaping
and that's exactly what I think
people actually pay money for at the end of the day.
I think that's
true  Same for Tomorrowland and I
think if you manage to establish a brand
and position the festival like that
then people will buy
tickets on their own apart from having
that works at Tomorrowland that
works here there are a few
festivals here
I think the emergency start here just
foil why does it  It's not even more
complicated than that at the same time
and you
basically need a team that
drives this vision 100%, so we as about
users are not the organizers,
we are the company that joined the company
that already had the festival before us
but it was very small and we
just got involved and made it much
bigger and first of all I think
you can't let a festival grow too much
inorganically I don't have it
healthy as festangea has
now doubled compared to 29 19 and
changes every year  An average of
15 to 25%, which is a lot for a festival
because most festivals are
currently in decline, so that's
solid growth, but I think it
would be unhealthy to say we
want 40,000 from one to the next
because you need a lot of complexity
this organic growth or
organic moderate growth for too
many of your quality and now if we had to
build a festival from scratch, so to speak,
with the growth rates you can
calculate how long it takes for you to
somehow be at a big festival
and then get involved somewhere, it has to
be something  what
this type of festival
embodies that we want and there
just aren't many of them, yes and I
think that at the end of the day there are just
a lot of other ways
to do marketing in some way, that's
a rather complicated way, okay
so festival boxes  Otherwise
we saw each other every now and then but
at least we didn't speak on the podcast
and you were generally a bit
reserved and in the last few months
I haven't read or heard much from you elsewhere
um how
come I'm actually doing my
first podcast in a while  Year apart
from above I Location that's the
only thing I've done here,
my colleague Rolf
here is close to my heart because it's
also different, it's about
content topics so
we do a little bit of the very
good program here and there  it's like
infotainment exactly and he but there it goes
uh there it goes then it's really about yes
clearly content things yes definitely yes
last 12 months were
hard but probably
somehow one of the hardest
probably of my 18 19 year old
entrepreneurial career because
at some point we  Yes, about a year ago we
actually realized that we were in a
bit of a crisis as an
industry and that we as about you
are now so big that
we
can no longer completely escape the centrifugal forces of the economy, actually
for two reasons, on the one hand um
[  Music] there is
a consumer crisis driven
by various factors,
inflation, but various other
factors that lead to consumers
generally being reluctant to buy.
Inflation for people having to
spend a lot more money on vital issues plus on
issues that are considered very important, such as holidays
also spend a lot more money
and of course you have to
save somewhere so if you are a bit
afraid of the future plus somehow you really have to save less money in your
wallet and then
you always save on the things that are not considered
absolutely necessary
and so fashion  That's part of it, so furniture
decoration and so on is also part of it, but
with fashion it's very much part
of it, so with the price segment that
means people basically
spent less on fashion, that was like
point 1 point 2 um all the experts
all the economists and  so on, actually,
in the curve crisis, it was thought that the curve will be
what extremely shoe added online
has ultimately
had a sustainable long-term effect on online penetration, so
people will shop more online after the crisis
than they would have done if the
crisis hadn't existed and  Um,
that didn't happen at all, so
online penetration today is where
it would have been according to the trend line
without a crisis and the two effects
unfortunately multiply with each other,
which means a lower overall market
demand in the area for which
has been multiplied by a
lower online penetration in the area
Fashion and that just meant that
the
absolute
online fashion volume was significantly lower
than the market expected.
Unfortunately, the market has to
buy goods with a 9 to 12 month lead in order to
achieve much higher sales and
logistics capacities  planned staff
hired, fixed costs built up, etc. and
that actually meant that
the online retailers,
especially in the fashion sector but also
in the home living sector, got into enormous
difficulties, including
you, so we
were suddenly confronted with far too
high inventories that we had to get rid of
Had to get rid of it means
reducing prices at the same time,
cost inflation, that both sandwich
basically once your margin away um
logistics capacities that are not used
in the outbound but the ones that
are full suddenly have to count in front of the
warehouse or somehow throw goods in
and at the fixed costs and that's all
I would say that's where I
think there were a lot of moments in 2022
where I really thought about how to do it
and it also threw me off track a lot.
I think we're going to
experience a lot of bankruptcies in the
near future
and that  is also reflected in the prices
ultimately, for example, as the UK
market leader traded at almost 0
enterprise value, the global fashion
group is virtually the market leader in all the
emerging markets under Enterprise below
0 Metal, so to speak a negative value, in
other words the principle can be assumed
that the company will go bankrupt
Having money in the account or something like that or
less than well, but there are many
companies in the industry that
were really very successful and were viewed as very
successful, that is
really existential, that
is an existential need, at least from the
perspective of the capital market but also from
my perspective too  Really also in the private
sector and of course I wanted to
make sure that again under no
circumstances was that included with my with
my two co-founders yes and
that's why the last 12 months were
characterized by yes austerity measures of
crisis management you can say in a certain
way I think it is too  Well
done now, looking back, I think
we always have. In retrospect, you can
always say that we could have recognized
the whole crisis earlier, but when you
call our suppliers and so on and
then you ask who were they the first to
call you and
say  or reduces the order
then you usually hear Zalando Credits
to Berlin they really recognized it earlier
but shortly after two weeks it
was our turn so we
recognized it very early I would
say and so most of the market participants
were there for months  Later on, you
actually always know the
situation and react and I
think we
reacted with the appropriate speed,
but we have two three
core measures so cancel orders, you
would have to lay off people because the
seas are a hundred or exactly so  Order
training where possible but you
usually can't do it, yes that means
you will, of course, you can
then reduce the orders you then write
but that always has an effect 12
months later, so we
still have over stocks  If you
basically divide the value of the goods by the
sales, you can see that the entire market
is sitting on overstock until today so
mega expansion stop or slow down but
also reduce staff so we have
shrunk a bit of staff now
here but here, um, we are
lucky it was her  in quotation marks
luck that's why
we can use the fluctuation of course, we have around 10 to 15%
structuring that's actually so
typical in the digital sector,
you can use that first, that means every
essential thing to somehow keep a lot
less new
but we also have a few fixed-term
contracts where  Of course, you
still have to take a closer look at the permanent or
probationary periods and
have already reduced staff,
not now the giant the giant
adjusting screw is one but there is
no huge adjusting screw ultimately
the goods management and your your
fixed costs actually at the logistics
level  That's a lot higher for free,
what can we do so tasty but
still empty so discounts
are perfectly clear but he
also has to do them skillfully you can't just
somehow do a shield push everything
in half or or so that
's not that  luckiest so
because what happens when you say everything is 50
% up is um the demand does
n't change in its basic structure that
means you have in your you have every
dealer actually has a kind of um
when you say you always say yes subdivision
so that's kind of like 20  % Items that
are doing extremely well, they are selling
incredibly good ones,
you actually don't have enough of them and then you
somehow have a medium build and
somehow have a few bums, yes what is now
50% on everything that happens, people
run even more towards the big sellers and
yours  The bums are still left behind,
but she has the best sellers even without 50%.
The bums
actually want to get rid of them, which means that this
is actually the unluckiest pricing strategy, but in fact the one
that many people
chose because they
were initially technically able to do other things
is, of course, more likely to be
discounts  to drive the
product-specific that you just
say the bum, I reduce it more,
the racer, I don't reduce it at all and
then also at the country level,
you have different
price sensitivities in countries and ideally
at the customer level, that is,
if you have three  If you look at customers,
you can actually do
a kind of
price sensitivity analysis or
price sales curve for each customer for each product and look at them and
know, okay, customer A with product A
might react at a 10% discount. Customer
would only react at a 20% discount and
customer C would  buys one way or another regardless
of the discount and then of course an
ideal promotion strategy is actually
to optimize price customers or product customers in a kind of matrix. You ca
n't achieve a 1:1 ratio like that but you can
cut on different attribute levels. Country is one level but  yes,
of course you can also
drive at a granular level, but
of course it is also a big technical
challenge. We have a product
catalog of 600,000 items, we have
well over 10 million customers in 29
countries, so you can imagine that
this will be a
complicated formula  At the end of the day, yes,
you think that for Germany,
at least the question is that in the
next few months, let's say 18
months, the economy will
pick up again and this consumption
will come back again, so
I don't know, nobody knows, and
it's also very volatile  In the
opinion of what the economists are
somehow saying,
I think what is
at least foreseeable is
that we will see growth in the online sector again from 24,
because in 2022 and
23, e-commerce was declining, that it has
never existed before, but e-commerce has always
grown  The fact that we were affected by
this high pandemic where it came
and the other penetration fell so sharply
combined with the
consumer restraint was down 22 23
and that ultimately
led to interesting effects because
many analysts, especially in the capital market,
ultimately say I'm
extra polishing  Ultimately it's just
the past into the future and there
are a lot of capital market analysts
who are simply
painting falling trend lines on principle and I don't believe that
at all and fortunately most experts don't believe that either
but I'm pretty sure that
from 24 we will too  We
will actually return to the
growth levels that we saw before the curve
and also roughly on the
trend line we would have had without the curve,
which means that eCommerce will grow
somewhere between three and eight percent, depending on the country in Europe, which is
good news because we are after  After two years of
headwinds and a declining market,
we are finally in a growth market again
and that is really what I have
learned is relatively crucial if you are in
a rather shrinking market and or
then you are actually in the
distribution value or are you in a
growing market yes and it is always
better adults  Being a market
solves a lot of problems, I would say,
or makes things a lot easier and
the question of consumer restraint.
I don't know whether we'll get back to pre-
crisis levels, but I guess
it won't be any worse than it is now,
and I'm accordingly  Now here
again in the podcast or
in general I think you can say we
have managed to stabilize as a company and
we have now also achieved a
very good Q1, yes profitable
on an operational level at least exactly so the
needs are adjusted and
we have positive cash flow  generated
and Q1, which means we believe
Q2 will now be in loss, but that's the
nature of it, so to speak, the sale phase where you
always have high losses, which means that's
not bad either, but we are very
confident that we will complete the entire thing operationally
profitably and that
our  Cash is enough and to the extent that I am
now actually looking
at the future much more optimistically, I have
the feeling that there is light at the end of the
tunnel, but
I still think 23 will be a brutally hard
year and we will somehow be there last time
when we met briefly
have talked about
it, many startups have gone bankrupt
and
many consultants have gone bankrupt
and I think we will see many more bankruptcies in
the next six to nine months,
including from people we
know or or we
will be happy together, I think  On the one hand, you also
somehow borrowed money
or invested it or something like that and
then for me it was similar and in the
end it didn't work out well, so you
have to say I so it
threw companies off track because I never
thought it would  Okay, yes, because of
Cloppenburg, it's
kind of a case in the fashion industry, but also many, many
people I know who I thought
would always get money or they
would always be able to
land orders somehow or something like that
are actually broke and are gradually
looking for the job
but also companies and startups and
I think above all those who, so to
speak, did not take the crisis seriously
and simply
did not react quickly enough, in
principle to the new world and  the new
world is capital costs a lot of money
so capital costs are very high
margins are under pressure and you have to
optimize costs you have to save and have
your liquidity under control let's say a
few words I know that this is of course
very difficult and you are there too
Probably somehow yes, I have to
listen to it, but I still have to go to the
stock market price for you, so I mean it
's stable now, but of course
we want it to be far away from that, so
the company is growing everything back in,
I don't know, but yes, the stock market price is of course
still a spectacle if  If you
look at it, we're somehow still
around 75%, our under issue 30
still says because it's been around the same
level for 12 months,
somehow more or less sometimes more sometimes
less, yeah I think
we're 1.31,  4 billion brand cap
or know available but
not exactly in mind now um so that
being set we
have our investment banks built from 12
companies the person in our
business and they are actually the
second best performance
which is the best performance boost that is
a  Scandinavian player is
better because they are in Scandinavia.
Scandinavia doesn't really have all these
crises, so
Scandinavia is going great for us too, so there
is no
consumer crisis and so in Switzerland.
If we were only in Switzerland
everything would be great, yes there is  a few countries
that are a bit like the islands of
hope and Switzerland and Scandinavia
are part of it and we knew they were
a bit protected by the Scandinavian presence,
but everyone else
and all of us are at about the same
level and everyone else is behind us
yes, the average, the
average e-commerce company in the
fashion lifestyle sector, it has
a few features, e.g. to Asos
Zalando, so to speak, pset has
lost 90% of its value in the last two
years, it's brutal what a
loss of value has taken place  That means
if you need cash again,
planning is incredibly
expensive, but after the new level you have to
give up an incredible number of shares
and get fresh cash in, so
I think
that was the poster child of this industry,
profitable market leader UK presents in
US  Felt mega well positioned,
everyone knows Acers does, I don't know exactly,
it's actually in their head but
somehow 4 billion in sales about mega mega
successful Market cap of 500 million
euros and they were even lower
and then had to travel in money on the valuation of 100
million, that is  Do
you have an improvement of somehow 20%
and that as Asos Ace that used to be
well over 5 billion so that
's really hot that
was always discussed in the background
at least so there are the old
rumors if you do it often enough with extra
yokes  or something like that at some point the
merger will come now or when will the merger come
so but there you are probably
can't say that we are doing it intensively
but so any comment on
it would make sense but
going together in that phase knew that it's
so bad at Zalando too
obvious because you have at least some of
the same ones, so you think about something like that in
general. Consolidation is an issue,
so conservation is always an issue,
especially in times of crisis, so it's
obvious that rumors always
arise that the Kaisers probably
don't comment on, but I think
consolidation can do two things  Things
mean players that go out of the market
and players that go together and
I think both will happen,
but it could be that it plays a role,
I can't
comment on that, well, who knows
for you, they
're doing incredibly well despite everything
your internal, um, commerce, let's say
software that others offer where
their shops are, they
can map the whole system with that they look
really good, yes I think the money
is probably one of the
built
the word I would say scale with
alpsole written because there were
your technicians exactly we have our
principle our software productized
as they say in 2018 even back then
fries cloud was still built since 22
M22 SC and yes, I think it is a so
I think that is probably
one of the reasons there is  Two reasons
why our share price
has developed better than the others is
that we are still growing, almost no one is growing
anymore, so actually almost everyone
had a decline in sales last year and
this year too and but the
probably more important reason
is money, which is a software
service  unit was also spun off in a short time,
so in short it also has its own business.
So far it is only a so-called
Business 400 and under this
we sell the software that we have built ourselves
to large online retailers and brands,
so the target groups are retailers and brands that
prefer 100 million in online sales
and the city ultimately provides me
with a software that basically
competes with Sales and SAP, they are
the market leaders in the area of ​​enterprise
shop software in this
hot money area and yes, very
successfully, we have almost 19 million in the Sky
business unit last financial year
Sales made very
profitable yes or yes he is animal
curring so is but over half
of it is so-called tech-aira i.e.
recurring sales the
sonata subscription sales exactly highly
profitable sales so the business is
mega profitable we have 27 million
um
you made so over 30  % margin and
that in quotation marks although we have
grown very, very strongly, of course
also in accordance with somehow
investing sales and co. So extremely
successful I think if it
were a separate company,
yes I think scale has a chance of
us knocking out the second unicorn in Hamburg,
yes, um  because I believe it will be yellow
standalone
if the market
recovers a bit again because these aas
companies have also been hit hard, you have to
say that they just sat e-comfort
30 40 so with the sales in 2021 it would be
cool but something like that from Unicorn that's
100%  Clearly now it's unclear you do
n't know in the end you can never say exactly
what a kind of business unit is worth
but I hope or I have the feeling that
we are doing quite well
there e-com has also
been really under pressure  Because many
companies ultimately
want a platform and we also count on the implementation
of our customers, which means that
if our customer somehow makes 10% more
sales, we also somehow make roughly
10% more, but in the last two years
the customers have lost sales on average
That means we
basically sat down or
lost revenue with our existing customers because we
have a so-called model that we
basically bill as a percentage, which in itself is
a good business model because the market
is actually growing, but in the
last two years it was rather
difficult  I would say it was
in a very difficult market,
but it still grew and was still
profitable. I think that shows how cool
this business model is and I am
very, very bullish
on the future of scale. I was
recently at Deichmann in Essen. The podcast
is coming out  I'll be out next few days
because Heinrich and Samuel
Samuel Deichmann are always
building it. I'll let it work for a while and
the two of them raved about the scale.
I think that's one of them that
a lot of customers comment on. I do
n't publish it at all, but if the samura can, I can
also say so I think it has already been
communicated publicly so exactly the
Deichmann Group including Ochsner
Snipes deichmann has
decided to use the money is
of course a big account for us
yes I don't know about turnover
mentioned but they already have very
significant online sales  I think you can
say that, yes, um, and
of course a large
account, but we now have
well over 100 online shops that
run on Sky, including a lot outside of Mode
Fielmann here as a Hamburg company,
which already has it here in the podcast, for
example  a skill customer but
also somehow yes depot in the home living
area FC Bayern Marco Polo Tom Tailor
also fun fact captain and son to build your
investment or your whole idea on scale
one of the very few topics
where I think our other regular guest Sven Schmidt
misjudged himself years ago
He didn't think there was a
podcast, let's just
say that it only focuses on it and you have to say that it was probably there and he was
probably paid back, yes, then in most cases it was
a good theory, but I do
n't think that was right. Yes, yes, yes,
yes, I respected it  if mega
mediocre and I still remember I can
100% remember the situation when I was
sitting in our office and really
sweating and with this podcast
because if there was something like that that was messing with it
so in the end you don't know there was
one  I bet I think now
most e-commerce films are of the
opinion that a B2B is, um, very good,
so Amazon is
on a completely different evaluation level.
I think if Amazon were to divide itself
into retail, hey double, the hosting
service, somehow video and so on,
I think so  I'm pretty sure the
most valuable thing that they currently have is
basically actually offering B2B services from a trade out
of trading sets and from a
scaled trading infrastructure
Groupen has
other companies that are trying to do this, so to speak. I
think with the software
area we have taken the profile of the most
profitable area but
also the most difficult area to build and
the one with the longest cycles in the end
always a game to say okay we are
so sales  huge, we're just starting to
express separate disciplines, so to speak, so everything has already been
learned that you can buy planes here with logistics,
anything else, you just got
the right one, do
you just believe that in
general, I'll come back, something will come
back, so first we'll
talk about it  one day again, um, but that's what she
said now, as
such, that was always the case in the past.
With me, you always have so active
turnover at least twice the company's value
or have you just become cautious now and
permanently believe or do you know
that the business can do that too  his Turks
have returned with the whole thing and everything that has
n't been seen as a problem for years.
I think the view of the
business model is still the same.
I think the question is what is what,
so to speak, what are the long-term
growth prospects of e-commerce?
there are different opinions from
somehow -5 to +10 which is of course a
total driver for value the question
in principle is how big can it become in
the future the second question is what does
capital cost
when the cost of capital falls again
the company will slowly
hear it again  That's basically
the same old question when I
tell you Philipp, I'll
definitely pay €100 in 5 years, what is the
option worth today that you
'll get €100 in 5 years and the question of how much
it's worth to you depends  from the question of what
capital costs and in times when capital
cost nothing,
the option to get €100 in 5 years might
cost you today maybe €90 for yes
and with high interest rates you pay
significantly less so ultimately
capital costs are high and have a high
leverage effect  Evaluation of
growth companies
and I think the third factor is,
I would say, the conference
or question of the so-called target margins in
this business model, i.e. how
much profit can you
ultimately get from the sales x targets, yes and
there, but that is actually unchanged
I think the market all
assumes that an EBIT margin of around 10 to 12%
can be achieved with this business model when fully grown.
The only question is when will the
full-grown state be reached? There is
now new competition from Asians
and also how much target sales are
there  no and you get back to
multiples of two I don't know but
I mean at the moment the reality is
that I think on average in the
e-commerce industry we are at multiples of
0.10.2 no and
I don't think so  that this is now the
situation sometimes you might think if
you followed the
Twitter and and what Insider platform a little bit,
so there was a K5
conference and Alexander Graf
made such a provocative statement that
somehow Zalando was
the new Karstadt  only without escalators, so that
went through the industry a bit, um,
can you gain such
consideration in the sense
that I think I'm
ultra paranoid and I'm always afraid that
we
're the Karstadt, so to speak,
or that we'll become the Karstadt  because we do
n't take something seriously because
I've experienced it myself. We were,
we were, and to this day I think we're
still attackers and as an attacker
you always see potential and are
always happy when your competitions do
n't recognize this potential or do
n't take you seriously  No, I still miss that
time sometimes, it does
n't matter exactly and now the
attackers are coming, so now we're at
a size where there are people out there
who, like Alex, are now
walking around pointedly and saying yes, these about you,
that's kind of an old one  Guy with
dreadlocks who doesn't understand the world
anymore space yes so
exactly because yes these are the
Asians who are now attacking a lot so
Tim yes is so that's an attack where
that would have that could otherwise cost me something
yes I have two looks at it
On the one hand, it's impressive what they're
doing,
at what speed they're
ethering, how much developer power they
have, what they're pulling out of the country
is pretty crazy and they also
have a different approach and in
some ways, for example, what
I found quite exciting was that  do they think
how do they think in customer
lifetime video so we always say okay
I have acquired customers how much
contribution margin can I ultimately generate with the customer
over time and
we optimize for that very much
and then of course there are different
drivers which the Asians are much
stronger at  to do is to think about a gate,
which means that the Asians
try to pull you off every day
and they say that the
most important thing is because then you will
convert and I always only have one example,
for example, you can see it on
many of these platforms
somehow buy a cell phone for 1000 €
or you can somehow buy a cell phone
ticket for 1 € with a 1,000
chance of winning then the cell phone has
very clever then you open up a new
target group of people who
can somehow pay 9 € not a thousand but
Their idea is that you buy the ticket,
that's one touchpoint and then
three days later you have to see whether you
've won. The second touch is basically in
two touchpointers. That's just a
completely different logic, which I find
interesting, which is impressive  They
also have a lot more
gamification on the go, they have a completely
different approach to promotions, they
do a lot of micro
incentives, so you often get
5 cents for something or
10 cents, yes, and they really encourage you
to do certain things  for
supposedly little money but maybe
scrolling shows exactly
200 products
somehow you get 5 cents or something so you
download the app you get x and you
constantly get discounts is
felt flashing everywhere and so on so there are
a few things like that  I think
you're really impressive, I
also think they're copying, um, and there
are also a few things where
I think they're done a little bit in Asian style,
so it
doesn't quite work on the European market, but the
Asians are smart enough to do that
too  to find out and start adapting,
so from my point of view there is no
protection against them
becoming successful, not everything is perfect yet, but
they are also the only ones
on the market in the short term, but there is
another side that is a kind of
regulator
Many people don't know this page, but for many
Asian players it is often cheaper
to send a package from China here to Hamburg
than it is for us to
send a package from Munich to Hamburg, which avoids
non-stop customs costs, which as
far as I know is the same  It's a
bit controversial whether they always, in
principle, pay the VAT sensibly.
I don't know exactly,
but it's a bit higher,
and the production is
also super awesome. Actually, there are
various test studies, all sorts of things, um
where the products are basically tested
were and were determined
relevant part of the products that are
sold you are not allowed to
sell in Germany are not put into
circulation but are still
put into circulation so that all said um
you have to say that is nothing about
which I think it is unfair per se
because the player  In my opinion, you can use the options
that the regulations allow you to
simply not comply with the player, that's
exactly what happens when it's imported, so I would
n't do that, but ultimately I
always find it difficult when you do something like that.
I don't want to cry about it a little
yes, because but I mean you
could demand that the
regulation is in place and that it is also
enforced, so if you say
these fractions should actually
be sold and whoever sells anyway then
it's somehow when you say
okay why actually yes yes because  the
state just doesn't
have all the stories
on the screen yet, so it's a
quality issue, they don't have
this whole customs world post on their screen,
you have then Zalando or many
other big players would have to
lobby exactly about it  It's
actually relatively clear now, but it's
nothing. Let's really
call Robert or something like that. People
somehow talk together somewhere
or someone requests
a government or something like that because that's
already if it's
harmful to ours and there  The
economy isn't exactly running great, yes, something is happening right now,
so that's what you have to
say, salad only plays a really
important role because, as the largest
market, they of course ultimately
have the best access and their colleagues
there in Berlin are also doing something,
but of course  Are there other sectors
that have learned to lobby for decades?
The e-commerce sector
is not one of them. I think the e-commerce sector is
simply much worse in
terms of finding access to politics and
regulation.
I still think it's a matter of
time before it's solved
It's being addressed, there are
more and more people on the radar who work at the
shitty central offices, but there are
still surprisingly fewer of them, so the
extent of the problem for online
trading from a European perspective is,
I think, not yet completely transparent, at least to many politicians
say from a politician's point of view, there are
other problems right now, yes, so he can
understand that, there are more important
issues in the world than the
question of whether we now value the toxins in
Timo's clothing somehow
in Germany, wow, that's
very difficult to say  But I can
tell you they spend over a billion
a year on marketing, that's
more to me in Europe, that's more than about
you has spent on performance marketing in its entire history
so they're really going all out
with marketing here
only via tiktok also via meters um
you see everywhere in
my opinion also because they know
that these I say in
quotes
I want the advantages that are
currently being used yes or the subsidies
that are currently being used
are not permanent and I think if  If
I were that, I would now
give it my all because um that's
like if if if the if the
European German or European
taxpayer in principle a kind of yes
I don't know what discount 20 voucher
is in the shopping cart for every buyer here
yes and that  The reality is that
taxpayers are currently subsidizing
purchases from Chinese players,
but as I said, I don't want to cry about it,
I don't want it to
be misunderstood because that's
capitalism, yes, and that
's fine with that. I'm fine with that, that's
capitalism  we have chosen
and that's fine and that's the
competition and if
we have to deal with it we have to
deal with it and we have to
find answers and you can just as well ask
questions, well why do
n't we just ship from the factory in
China again if that's the case  It's cheaper,
you have to say,
because at some point you'll have conflicts because it
's of course total nonsense from an environmental point of view, of course it makes
a lot of sense from an environmental point of view to ship the whole thing here in a ship
on a container
and then basically store it centrally and
then send it to the end customer rather than
somehow via
To send some things in here by airmail, um, and
you have to say that the Chinese, apart from
the subsidies, have also really
managed
to build logistically very efficient routes here, yes,
because such quantities are also being
pushed through here, but all this
marketing and tik tok are going away  Well,
I mean, I listen to the
Heinemann and Graf podcast on
Kassenzone every now and then. The others talk about how
to master Tik Tok, so the
Chinese companies, yes, it's
partly like that, but partly you have to
say that they do it and
they also solve a lot of
problems  with money no, so if you
say today you want to build a new
huge brand, make the glass to tiktok
no, but I say the question is
nice if they now
have to pay the real price of what it
costs what they have in their logistics,
so to speak  Actually, we would have had to pay
in terms of product quality and
since the question was whether it
would be worth it to the extent that it was, um,
some years, some no, so
you have to say that the arrowind
participant also comes about through the
scherzala, so to speak
No, nevertheless, that's why I do
n't want to downplay it. You have to
say that the performance they provide
and the innovation they bring is
already there. So I don't think that
a squint or a Timo
is the next one and that's why there was
a lot of hype and  so on, and then it
somehow imploded because there was
actually little substance behind it.
I think that's what I would say
is dangerous, that what we're
seeing right now from Timo and animals
and co, that the substance is combined
with the substance is really the money
combined with a pension like that and that
just makes them both relatively similar,
so I honestly bought it myself
but I would say the apps at the end
are themselves are comparable rails
and Timo
I think if you look at the apps
the product range is a bit like
me  I think the philosophy, the DNA,
it's really similar, yes,
so they are
business models, they're not that
similar, so somehow the topics have to
be a pure marketplace.
Ultimately, it's essentially the seller of the
goods, so there are big
differences. I think it's similar from the customer's point of view
They are sharing Timos so it
seemed clear fashion that as
chemo um the way the app
looks is different but
I think the philosophy from which
it comes is similar,
I think it's kept private, yes many
large American restaurants I know  To be
honest, not 100 billion
reviews,
I honestly don't know,
I didn't deal with that, but when I was
supposed to go public again it was of course
cool because then I had a bit
more transparency. The question is where the
university is, but I heard
that  So we're now moving
into the complete rumor corner here, but I
've heard that they
want to set up a universe in the USA.
Now we've already spoken a lot about
China and, so to speak, as a
big extra for you, we'll say a
few words about the other giant  Topic
since the last time I
did it there was something like this or AI,
that was a term that you
heard from time to time and but it was just
close to today when everyone is talking about it and
it somehow felt like it was on everyone's agenda
What surprised me about it
now also played a big role for you, what is
the about you area philosophy? So I
think everyone else was surprised
by the
quality of GPT, um, and that also
changed something in me, in terms of how I view things
and so on  I think it's a certain
irony of fate that 10 years ago
people always said just don't be
a taxi driver or a craftsman or a
truck driver because that's the first thing
the machines or somehow no
idea in the factory or something like that is the
first thing the machines  if can
so text was but also no longer
the self-driving cars or somehow
we are still two steps
away and so and and do something
creative or do marketing or world
programmer like a fast forward what do
we have now what do we see now  Yes,
you can't even manage
to build a Billy Regal somehow.
No one has seen self-driving cars. Yes, but
somehow creativity, the EA can
write songs, can produce crazy art, can
write poems, can formulate crazy things, yes
can write articles,
can program, yes, so we say
somehow it's pretty wrong  in the
question of what will actually be the first
area in which AI will actually
make a breakthrough, I thought that was
so crazy when I saw it,
I thought how wrong we
were in the question of what will be the first
area  in which Cain
experiences a breakthrough because AI has yes or that has
now also been seen through open air
etc. It makes creativity much more
efficient but it makes programmers
much more efficient so through Co-Pilot
and other applications developers have
suddenly become many times more productive
yes and  That was surprising for me
to see in which
field it was actually the first to
experience a mass breakthrough, otherwise
the hype is of course crazy, and
the feeling is that all the reasons are now just
the whole thing.
E-commerce was very much earlier, then the
social web existed then  a wave
of social networks then somehow
meter worst crypto and now
the new saudius
is being driven through, I think it's a more
sustainable and more substance
filled pig than now
kryptonmeter-verse those were and nfts um
but I think we'll just see  what's
somehow left over when she
puts a little bit of half of it in? We
of course also work on a
variety of
shopping boards that you I'm
convinced that if you
go to an online shop in three or four years, you'll have
the opportunity to communicate with a bot like this
via text and white and with
about you then somehow saying hey
I'm at a wedding in Italy
next week and which the bot knew I know your
age your gender your
taste interprets the wedding
somehow festively interpreted Italy
next week a
weather forecast is white  All right, somehow
28 degrees, yes, and can
then make some cool suggestions based on that,
so I think that not everyone
will shop like that now, but I think
it will be a relevant shopping case
snap nothing next to search and somehow
categories navigation in an online
shop  yes, we are working on it, for example, but
we are also working on it in the area of ​​product refinement or are working with me a lot.
Objections in the area of ​​search
customer service, of course, yes, um, we can get great
savings potential, yes, so there
will be countless
use cases and I think the
e-commer is in total  will also be
more efficient and magically stronger,
okay, but it means you are
using solutions that already exist or
have you hired your own developers to
build new applications, so to speak, yes, we are building
new applications but on the basis of
Openair, so that is what is happening now
Actually, you also do a lot so that you can
basically use the possibilities that
the Open Air or other providers
have, there are now also solutions from Google,
so these llms, so to speak, that they are used
and with the help of the llms you
ultimately program applications
that have a high level of quality with little use of staff
Achieve for which you
would have previously developed a marten,
yes, I also find that
really impressive when I saw
the first applications that I
saw from people in our
company, developers but also
sometimes not on a daily basis, not
developing the technology DNA but
why  Servants were suddenly able to program on the
basis of open
in a very short time, that
's simply a huge
advance in productivity, by
the way, these large language models
are now available from
so for meter 1 from Google and from above
okay, you can say that
otherwise there are still  Not there are
n't that many real managing
directors yet, so the main thing is that
the question is, are there
actually new businesses now or
is there more of a stand-up and business
built into the background or or where
is one of those?  Case or
Kay wow that's a new company that
can now make money with it, I have
n't seen any yet, yes I think
at the moment we're actually seeing a lot of features
within
business models, no,
I think there's also Word or Excel and Chor, I
'm also a NATO pilot  Um, exactly, it really
leads to new companies, so
in a certain way it already does a
new company, but it is now
basically it will lead to a wave of new
companies or will or that
the A1 is just an encroachment,
so in principle they have  are now
experiencing a breakthrough or is
n't it more the case that in principle it
leads to existing business models
becoming more efficient and existing
platforms releasing features that
otherwise couldn't have been released?
I feel like at the moment it's more
the latter, so that's good for you
then when the costs
go down then it becomes more profitable again,
what is the experience better no,
you have to say the
biggest competition we
still have as an online retailer would have to be
offline competition, yes and the question is,
it won't just be more efficient  in the
sense of increasing the stomach but also
the experience, so if we have something
like a great shopping bot that
is able to give really good
advice, then that is of course
an edge compared to our
online competition if we
are somehow faster than others  Above all,
a total edge compared to
offline, because you can hardly find
a cool consultant who
can explain what you have to do at a wedding
like you Philipp now has a super
cool appearance at the wedding in
Italy and we are an online shop
But if we
could get it online then that would of course
be part of the question. At the very beginning it
was also the question of what is
actually the growth prospect in the
online sector is somehow
two percent every year or maybe it is
somehow 8  or 10%.  I think
these are things that
can improve the customer experience so much that there will be
a little growth
on the stock market for two years. In
hindsight,
that was the direct decision until
today. I think that's a
bit of a question if you think about it  like
when you ask someone whether it
was the right decision to turn 18 and be
of age so that's the way it is,
in a certain way sometimes you
have the company that somehow
raises capital at some point you have to
somehow make the value liquid
then  At some point in time, yes, I
think you have to say, looking back, that
of course the timing
was the best. I didn't really notice that in the situation. To be honest, I
have to say that at the time I was
more in favor of postponing the IPO for another
two years
Of course, it would have been a fatal
mistake in
hindsight, but no one saw it coming,
um, and it wasn't clear to me at the time
that we were basically at the peak of the
valuation, so I
assumed that the costs would continue
to rise and so would everyone else
A lot has changed for you privately because you have
also personally
lost a lot of assets, I mean if you still have a
relevant antenna so I believe in the
three percent or something like that then there is
a lot of money at least
Paper but it's gone, um, but maybe that has something in
your life, no,
how much money I have on paper
has never had such a great influence on my life,
okay, but it has changed my life
in such a way that
the pressure is on you
from my point of view  It's higher if
you're public, yes, and it's a
burden for me to know that people
believed in us, believed in me,
bought the shares and then, at
least on paper,
they're somehow negative or maybe
real - if they  when you
sold the shares, that's what puts a
huge strain on me. I was, before
Julia, I never worked with outside
capital, again with
bank capital or with investors'
capital. There were very small measures where
I took my investors in,
but it was always there  only a very, very
small extent because I actually because
I always knew that it was a burden for me
to accept the real money from others,
yes, and what bothers me most about it
is that we haven't even
accepted other people's money, that is, now
if you have one  If you buy a share from us,
the money doesn't flow to us or to the
company or something like that, but you
just somehow buy the money from the other side
or the share from the IPO,
which is of course different, the
companies flowed to, but ultimately
knowing people are somehow at a loss
By
buying the q share, I think
that you were generally surprised at
how much publicity an
IPO brought with it. You
of course had to make a story back then, yes, a
title was made back then, a mirror,
you can talk about it and so
now the time has changed  a little bit
changed now I recently saw at the
airport I was coming from a
magazine lying there somehow so I'm
coming what's all
difficult at the moment and you were on the title
so
the world has turned a bit like that and my feelings
If ST had made it less public,
the question doesn't
really arise because when you
go public, you always do a public
listing, so it's a
peril anyway, you go public,
ultimately you
can do it  I couldn't prevent it, I was back
then, even it was like that back then and whether it's like that
today that I always reject 99% of the
media requests, yes, so I've also
received various TV requests and what I like,
how many talk shows and magazines
and interview requests and podcast
requests and so on  I'm going
on and I'm actually canceling most of it, but you ca
n't avoid the public
if you're on the stock market. It's
not in nature, so I do
n't want to present myself here
as if I was being forced
into public  Go,
I've always been someone who
was in the public eye or was
looking for the public in a certain way,
but I've always
really liked the niche, that's why
I love our podcast here, um 100,000
higher age
grow up but I
liked me  industry I liked special
interest business and I was always
not in the mood for such
popular press tabloid people
television individually
from a few years ago then you
still have the goal of
becoming mayor of Hamburg one day, a very
big washing machine there you are a
very big washing machine but  then
you also chose yes then it is part of
your business and for me
my part of my business public
was technically always economic sector
or internet digital sector yes and
when you go public you are
suddenly somewhere in a different
category yes you are that  I also
noticed in my person that you are
suddenly somehow, yes, I, when I
introduce myself or when you see the
doctor last time for a check like that, but
he has to state your profession, yes, and
I, like me, still have a
hard time on the board  Writing
company doesn't sound like something, that's how
I feel right, but that's
just who you are and yes, you're a
public figger with all the pros and
cons and but it also has advantages, yes
of course it's cool too, you can
somehow get the employees in through shares
centivize those who are liquid, you create
a lot of opportunities, you can
raise capital much more easily, which is
of course kind of stupid at the moment
because the valuation is so low,
but in theory you can
raise capital very, very quickly if you
want to, that's privately clear
more complicated and this transparency,
this accounting ability, which also has
a lot of positive aspects and the
capital market creates pressure and
this pressure is also definitely
positive for performance, so I want to
say it has a lot of positive
aspects but why is it like
growing up  It's also a
positive aspect, but sometimes
you remember your carefree
childhood and
someone thinks that it was really nice back then, um, that
's where we are right now because the whole
topic is and, so to speak, something has come
and gone  I've talked about
it, you know it with humor, it's back to normal with
you, um, I mean, I mean,
a lot of
companies right now have that feeling that Google, that's the trend.
Amazon was
already the trend six months ago, so that's going to be very
strongly again towards presence so
turned in a wide variety of areas yes
we were actually an early mover
when it comes to presence work we have been there for
I don't know how long
so clearly for a long time now
we have the rule
that you have three days  We had to be in the office every week,
we also specified the days,
so Tuesday Wednesday Thursday are
our bread days and Monday Friday is
remote, which means you can
come to the office if you want, but
almost no one does, so Monday Friday
maybe 10% of the people are in the office  and
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday all the
nuns are engineers in the office so in the
IT area we are fully remote um there is
no other way yes
sometimes once or twice a year we
do like an event here in Hamburg where
everyone comes over three days three four
days connected with  The cotox
usually somehow still connects with our
conference and so on but in
principle in the Def area there is no
chance of being present sometimes it doesn't make any
sense that is another work
in the non Def area so
I believe in this hybr mix so we  We
still have
two weeks of remote weeks twice a year or last
year we had a remote month in
January so that over the year you
get about 50 50 so 50% remote
50% presence and I think that's
actually the best because I  I believe that
remote work is very efficient, I
believe that people are more productive in the
home office and they are better able to
work on things in the home office,
but I believe that creativity, a
sense of unity,
informal exchange, all of this is difficult
to organize in a puremote
setup and that is also mega mega  What
's important for a company of a
certain size is I think if you
're small, if you have ten people,
15 people and they're all kind of
knowledge workers, then you can also
do a remote setup and you can handle
all of these topics in the remote setup,
I think  If you are a size like
ours, over 1000 employees, many
graduates, many career starters
who have never worked before, many
different departments, so there is
a lot of informal exchange that has to
take place,
which is very, very difficult to achieve in a fully
remote setup
and that is exactly the reason  I recently read why
many large companies are a bit too Zoomy,
so I
wanted to go back to the office myself.
Almost all of them do their hybrid setup,
so there are hardly any films that say 100%
presence, just as there are
now hardly any companies that
have
100 houses  % yes exactly yes yes that's true yes yes yes
but it's more of an exception and there
are still somehow 100%
remote companies. It's
also an exception from a certain size. That's
why I say but at a certain size
because I think fewer than 100 people work there  If
the game is completely different then
you can also do it remotely, but I
believe that when a company reaches a certain size and
complexity, I hardly know
any company with a certain level of
complexity that has remote access, but that's
why I believe that the
model we have always used is that
which is now actually being adapted by
the majority of companies, namely two to
three days of office presence and I believe
that what we do, at least
if you have a campus,
that I will enforce that, namely
that you specify the days because
in principle you ensure that there are  There are a
few days where everyone is there somehow with
us every Thursday so if
someone wants to celebrate farewell something
always Thursday because everyone knows that
Wednesday Thursday everyone is there and it
's citizens get into routines and so
on and like that  It
was already with us before the curve, so if you
feel sick, then of course you
go down, so in the days you
have Monday Friday, so
as I said, I think the
productivity in the home office is it
for completing tasks and
then that's it  the people have
the tasks automatically on the exact days,
so I think if you just
want to work quietly and somehow
want to process Toulouse then it's much more
efficient in the home office and I think
when we announced this
in our company and said
we wanted to  Three days a week presence
then I was also accused several times,
or we were
accused of being skeptical about working
from home, whether people really
work, whether they are really more productive,
and I always say that
I have always been convinced of that  I
know or I am convinced that
productivity is higher in the
home office, but this topic of creativity
in the form of exchange,
corporate culture, how it feels like you are
copying something, is all extremely
important and it is also part of the
success of a company, which is why
I believe in it  With this mix, imagine that when
you started your career in the office you
basically didn't have the opportunity
to look at other people, so that's
so important, so you learn
at the beginning, even if you're 40 or 50
with 20 other people who don't know what
Collaboration is then you can
also do it remotely, you do
n't need all that anymore, you can do it
with the exchange and so on and
so forth, yes, but if you
're collaborating with a young herb,
it's simply important that you
see each other, that you
can copy things from each other, that you chat over a coffee
machine, that you have
a little drink in the evening,
talk about things and so on and
all of that doesn't work in the remote
in the fully remote setup, which is why
I always believe in this hybrid  Setup
I'm thinking about
it again, we're a factor, there's just
no
strong announcement.
I have the feeling that it's
already clear to most people that I'm also a
fan of education if you have a certain presence,
but there are now no
regulations for Corona  So the
pandemic regulations continue to apply, so to speak.
We're trying to make the office attractive,
but I always ask myself when
I read about it from Google or from
Amazon or from you or or
from people recently, okay,
we wouldn't have to  because somehow we also
have a stronger regulation
that makes it even clearer for people:
you are always in the office, I'm actually
on the road, but when I'm not
traveling for work and you, I
try
to work remotely on Mondays or Fridays, ideally those too
Monday and Friday because then you also
have your sour quiet, so
I feel the same way. I get more done
when I sit at home. I
then have a quieter environment. I can
work more concentrated there. In the office, you're
somehow distracted, but
right now  this distraction so that's
this distraction can also
be an added value yes because you are
distracted by small talk by no idea
here hello here a chat
sometimes chat a bit
after the appointment again for a moment no so
I think so  I believe that
this distraction
can certainly create value, but of course it is
not actually conducive to working through topics
and I think my
experience is that remote meetings, for example,
always start on time, um in face-to-
face meetings you always somehow have
three or four minutes that are lost
because someone  comes too late because especially
if you prefer to
have three buildings and 23 floors just
the distances between the meetings,
so much time is lost ne and uh
remote meetings in shorter because you
just leave out all this smalltal stuff
and just quickly get going
come to the point and then you say bye
and that outside so that's just possible
everything that's easy to win in 1
that you have in the remote setup and that's
why I love this
combination and I actually try to
do Monday Friday remotely I
get  then often then somehow
appointments are set or something like that but I
like this this mix, his
work-life balance has changed in the
last few months with the whole thing
economic situation or crises stress yes
so I prefer live-balance has always been
very work-heavy  In the
last 12 months
I've been more work class, I don't have any
children or anything like that, that means so few
private obligations,
so I'm still
coming up with what's going on because what was that, so
to speak, there were some live for points
in the last few months less than the
festival heard now  Definitely the fact
that I rarely drink
alcohol during the week anyway,
why no one
drinks a little wine with dinner or something like
that, but that I
drink alcohol every day for three days in a row,
which only happens once a year
I also think it
had an effect on my brain cells, it was
quite good, it wasn't that often, but there weren't any
blatant live higher ones  We've
accumulated a lot of them, so
we've done a lot of international
collaborations, you have to
say, everything was sort of wrapped up in a 2021 period
where we
somehow still had the ambition
to expand faster, I would say, outside of Europe.
Many US stars designed them, so Bella did
Katy Perry emer Robert Smiley Barbie
Brown the stranger things
actress
Dennis Schröder and yes, that
's really a brutal package, so
there was a lot of beige,
you have to say that if we had known
what was coming,
we would probably have had a technical crisis  One or
two contracts were signed
but yes, so of course there was now some
blatant cooperation and it's also quite
funny. I was in Miami for a
year now for a conference and for
a few sky stories and so on and I
asked a few Americans
which year was less, less long
ago, yes, but if you now somehow ask an
American one of 100 American
women, best regards,
the probability that one or the
other about you know that's quite
funny but that means they know it
off the top of their head so they can't
shop  So very unambiguous checker
or we now have a
worldwide shipping option, including
to the USA but also to 100 other
countries, so you can shop with us,
we actually now
have millions in terms of
sales in the USA, but that's
natural  ridiculously little,
yes, so whether it's the USA or
another country, I don't know, but
basically, of course, this
offers us this international
cooperation that has followers
everywhere and the worldwide shipping
option of course offers us very good
data on the question of which
countries have potential  There is no and yes the
topic is not a priority for us at the moment
but at
some point it might
make sense, we 29 countries but everything in
Europe can make sense,
perhaps expanding outside of Europe
okay okay so that's
crazy  I mean,
to crack the USA, that would be really
awesome, so my dream would
actually still be the one that sub-loads our
vision into our comedy in a
pithy way then it says on
page 1 but vision is to become the global number
one and online fashion so that
includes that  I think that
includes number one, we're
not yet, we're European, but I do
n't think we're
number 1 in America yet, so
there's a USA, of course Amazon, but there's
not a big fashion player right now,
so I think it's the American
potential  This is a
model like a multiplayer fashion
shop, which is always the
managing director of Zalando and us,
for example, Acers. In
fact, there is more or less nothing tested in the USA,
but revolve is smaller than us and
revolve is completely bootstrapped
been highly reputable so
you can actually see that there is
a market so revolver is a
little more expensive but I'll say
slightly differently but revolved is actually
the American one about you so when
I talk to American investors
I say the revolver is a
little different  But the price point is
more or less similar, very social
media-heavy, very influential, very
big, yes, enormously successful, so I
think the potential for a multi-
brand fashion platform in the USA is
there, but that also works in
many other regions, so it's not
It's actually more of a
European model
and in the other regions it
just didn't get any funding. We were
just with our colleagues, which,
um, I think that the reason why
there is such a model is why I think, first of all,
my hypothesis is Europe  is ahead of
the rest of the world in e-commerce
except maybe Asia but definitely
ahead of the western world and
it's the only industry in which we
are better than the Americans and I
think we have the summer
to thank for that because they  We were able to
set up e-commerce models here in a highly efficient manner and, above all, to
raise a lot of capital, then demonstrated
that it was possible and then in
principle paved the way for others,
including us and about you, would
n't exist if it stopped  wouldn't have
been that successful either and
together they would basically have paved the way for it,
so have a look here
Olli is the inventor. I do
n't know him but I think he
very much deserves his sport and his Maldives holiday because of the people
I'm really serious about the service that they
have provided to the European e-commerce industry and
you can't overestimate it, it's quite
interesting to see where I'm at now
in the crisis, so to
speak
are family offices with a few
shares but no longer as much
power, so
this commerce
down cycle now seems to be
leading to them
actually at least ceasing their activities, well,
I mean I'm only coming in before the
curves were somehow something  such a means cool
no in we suddenly had a
little cool hype and now
of course it's the last industry you
would go into as an investor but your
plans are still intact so so to speak you
really say somehow 40 maybe
the 40 Berlin gone I'm gone now  34
then comes the teigmüller campaign,
actually in six
years there won't be that many of
Mr.'s terms of office in Hamburg are 5
years
so yeah, um well that's
also down to earth
I really want to relax for a long time
um I
'll
definitely read and do a little something
but here I'm keen to do a world resettlement
okay yes I'm really keen
on that, you can't
really get into that now  three weekends um
and then I actually read a lot
and then actually got
to grips with the topic of how you
can improve a city, so my goal and
now I also have an NGO that
is already called Podcast 145
and that  NGO's mission is to
make Hamburg the city with the highest quality of life in the world and
this NGO and I in the future
want to ask myself the question of how
can you make a city worth living in
for people to live in the city
and that's always the case  It's still my
idea to deal with it
after I'm out of Balty, which
is still a while away. You can
sail yourself and then you would
have someone's
license for a sports boat and I ca
n't really sail yet, but
I would seal the world
I wouldn't do it alone, I would get a chapter,
so I was at a
SAP event and
of course they talked about the SAP founders
and then you have to say
this, um, you have Plattner, he must
be such a universal genius
Not only did he help set up SAP and he's
a mega technologist, he's
also seen the Americas Cup, but
also because he's a sailor himself, so
the guy is completely into this
sailing himself and can
process it and  yes, but they
all do it, it's like a little bit of a
billionaire's toy, I have so
many, they all race like that,
so
I'm more like that with the catamaran,
nice with four knots, that the
wine isn't so nice, that it  Wine doesn't
sway so well, yes, um, I feel a lot of
knots, really lazy ass, so to speak, so to speak, to
drive forward, yes, they're
really competitive, they can
buy each other,
sometimes they're crazy
to employ this technological skill myself and
then I'm a
content type, so content is simple
and not so much
engineering but also
looking at boats or something like nautical science and that
's very engineering-
like or how it works but
okay  was then able to do something like that and he was
then able to build SAP and
you just need these lines live
people and I mean that is, as
always,
live
entrepreneurs like them and um also
a bit of global ambition that
America has also cracked with SAP, i.e. me  It
was artificial again, um but then on
the Christian little conversation and
SAP is just underrated like awesome
legs and that's that a German or
you German guys put the thing up
USA spoke and then so let's
build salads live thing
but relatively short football club  brought into the
first league and so on but it's
just sometimes you have to think about
what maybe it would be for you
really so really mayor is
of course but
whoever is even more possible yes you I I
think I listen to your podcast very, very
regularly  I always think it's
cool when you
have entrepreneurial personalities who
push life projects forward and I have
the feeling that it's more of a
dying breed, and you
're one of them, you own the company
here, um, and I always ask when we talk
I like you too, why are
you still giving everything here,
this pain, yes, and you're
always
excited about what I can do, yes,
and it's just very, very
long-term and like a
family business, you can
say it better, but in  Digital sector and I
think this type of entrepreneur is
a bit dying out and I
also go with it, I always say
I don't want to stay here with Word forever,
it's actually a shame but so do
you have Plattner who somehow raises SAP as his
life's work or
I also don't know that I want to build a Trigema or something like that,
this new network and I
think you need to get a few
people back to work, for example, he
's still extremely active and he's
really getting started. I haven't got the podcast out yet, if at all
heard but I think it's
cool
to see entrepreneurs like that and this ambition and
this so we also have a
long-term perspective but
also to advance yourself in this long-term
perspective in the company
that's just awesome
and I think that's the only way you can really do it
Also build a global company like that
but unfortunately I just don't have that ambition
professionally so
I think it's a shame I think it's cool
that you have that no I love the
less [ __ ] Tomorrowland
you can see that so well um you can't do it that
easily  Plus, of course, it's also a
big one, you're now doing
more than, by the way, look again at the
whole festival, I thought it was
outstanding again, but you're
now also doing more than the festival,
no, that's a lot, you
already need your OMR empire here  nationally
yes but
in the USA on the road
CEO Rock Nation you always get appointments
this yes so well not anymore
but if you look at your guests
and I am so what progress you have made here in
the last few years
if you do that  now
extrapolated to 10 to 20 years, so to speak,
then I think you can expect it again
and that's just cool, I think that there are
people like you and you have that
Plattner is also one of them, those in
a category that
the company belongs to or
at least that  He doesn't own the company
but he owns the feeling that
I think he has a lot of confidence in
this company and they simply say
hey, I have no plans at all
to get out of here, I'll actually do it as
long as I can manage it somehow or
I found the Trigema interview
by the way  also cool but
funny guy yes but so strange
view not true also not with
someone who was almost as funny as he
called Ostermeier but
somehow also cool yes so that he just
says with such passion his company somehow hey I
take responsibility here and that's
mine  Thing and I'm here, so to speak, I'm
here for the whole thing. I have to
say, I think it's great. I said a few things
to them about the chemistry,
but I think that's really really cool, so it's
true. I think it was
honestly still legs and he has
Then afterwards I bought the title
for the festival, so most people
would now have Philipp here, which is
now with us. I
had a reason
to say that I would like to come to a festival
and can you give me
a tick, um  He didn't do
that, wait a minute, my colleagues, now
look here, he somehow bought himself
and not okay, um, so
I actually thought it was really cool, although of
course his so if you're
over the groups now, it's been a
little while ago, but again as
Recap, um, amazingly, he doesn't have
this growth ambition either, he
'll make you 120 and 100 and with Fash
if you know that there would
probably be more in it, but
he also says that's enough for him and
that wouldn't be a risk  ready to
go and then he basically has it now
more or less holding it there as best as it
can, but yes, exciting podcast,
otherwise I can always recommend it
and the
colleagues are almost drinking something because they are
doing the documentary but I'm happy about it
you're back now
you're chatting again but it was
fun thank you there are many
more topics because they haven't been
spared now um
hopefully now again in a little
smaller intervals so maybe again
before Christmas or so I
would  I'm happy otherwise Rolf
can be heard in the education context
around education
last year the podcast with
both of us here was in the top 10 again
that really followed me, it
was actually a random episode in principle but
I'm somehow happy that so many
People here to listen to our our chatter here
preparation times somehow
WhatsApp back and forth what do you have for so
and then that's it then insofar as the
conversation what has now heard is thank you
very much thank you all clear ciao
[music]